We've never done a project where we could
see such a huge impact on the clients.
So individuals who are faced with mental health
challenges or economic challenges, having them try
to navigate all of these disparate systems, how
do we improve that process and that experience?
IBM solution really allowed for secured access to
the data that's all protected in our data center
from the cloud. What the IBM
product is bringing to the team
an ability for them to really care
coordinate, have a holistic view,
and then be able to set goals and manage
their cases right in that technology. With
Watson in the cloud we can actually engage and
interact with our clients anywhere, at any time.
We could really make a difference. We could
not only serve this population better,
we could also save money while we're doing
it. This system can be used for any number
of individuals or cohorts of individuals. It is
a blueprint for how we're going to provide care
across the county. Bringing
this technology to government
is really revolutionizing and transforming
the way that government does work.